at its most basic Avengers infinity war
is a movie that follows the tyrannical
Titan Thanos getting his purple hands on
the Infinity stones so he can activate
the Infinity Gauntlet snap his fingers
and wipe out half the universe's
population but spoiler alert the film
didn't actually show him obtaining all
six Infinity stones he already had the
Power Stone plugged into his gauntlet
when the movie opened infinity war
explained thunders his acquisition of
the gem through Thor who revealed that
the mad Titan decimated the war-torn
planet of Xander and captured the Power
Stone Rick
so why didn't fans get to see Thanos
actually do this in the film
co-directors Joe and Anthony Russo have
the definitive answer
with so many Infinity stones to focus on
one simply had to go during a Q&A
session with students our OS City High
School Joe Russo explained that he and
his brother thought the Power Stone
would be one too many to include in the
already super-sized clique saying
there's so many stones Santos has to
collect and you get into a trap and we
thought we knew where it was in
guardians of the galaxy so it was easy
to deal with it off-screen the Power
Stone was a crucial element in guardians
of the galaxy of the universe savers
traversing through space to acquire the
gem and keep it away from the cream
militarist Ronan the accuser ultimately
the intergalactic military and police
force known as the Nova Corps wound up
protecting the stone at the end of the
film unaware that Thanos was coming soon
anyone hoping to see Thanos is ravaging
of Sandara on the silver screen will be
pleased to know that Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige previously teased
it might be possible in guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 since it's part of the
origin of Richard Ryder better known as
Nova Feige one's told comic-book comm if
we have a big board with a bunch of
characters that have more immediate
potential Nova is on that board because
of the connection to the guardians
universe because there is more than one
example to pull from in the comics that
are interesting and you're absolutely
right he was in the earliest drafts of
the guardians of the galaxy whether or
not Marvel fans will ever get to witness
Santos snatching up the Power Stone
remains a mystery that only time can
solve thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
you
[Music]